[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير انا نانسي افران مين فيكم درس
بجامعه حكوميه يرفع ايده
المعظم
ومين فيكم
لبست المريول الازرق او المريول الاخضر
ترفع ايدها
برضو انا
ولدت وفي فمي ملعقه
ليست ذهبيه وليست فضيه بل عاديه ولدت وفيه
ملعقه عاديه
ولدت في مدينه الزرقاء وانا اخت شقيقين
وشقيقتين من ضمن عائله عاديه ومكافحه
والدي عمل في القطاع العام وبعدين صار
محامي ووالدتي عملت كمعلمه برضو في القطاع
العام لمده 20 سنه
مدينه الزرقاء وعشت فيها باول مراحل
الطفوله اجت في مدرسه خاصه درست فيها للصف
الرابع من الصف الخامس للتوجيهي تنقلت ما
بين ثلاث مدارس حكوميه وكانوا نسبيا
قريبين على مكان سكني فكنت اروح عليهم
ماشي على الاقدام
بعد هيك تخرج طبعا من مدرسه الاميره رحمه
الثانويه للبنات في الزرقاء وكنت في تخصص
العلمي جبت 89 دخلت جامعتنا الجامعه الام
مين الجامعه الاردنيه يقول لي
حلو كتير
تخصصي كان درس الاعمال ودرست فيها لاربع
سنوات وكان لازم كل يوم اخذ ثلاث باصات من
الزرقاء من المجمع القديم
للجديد للجامعه وارجع كمان ثلاث باصات
عوده
للزرقاء
تتخيلوا اذا محاضرتي الساعه ثمانيه يعني
لازم اطلع من البيت 5:45 عشان اوصل سته
ونص ليش لاني اذا ما طلعت بكير ما راح
اوصل لانه مجمع الباصات وللي كانوا في
الزرقاء او جربوا يكونوا يجوا من الزرقاء
لعمان بيعرفوا هاي الرحله
هاي مراييلنا متذكرينها
وهاي انا بس بشوها
ماشي
فانا لست بملعقه ذهبيه ترعرعت ونشات لغايه
اليوم وانا فضيه وانما
عاديه ملعقه السنبله اذا متذكرينها او اذا
[تصفيق]
فطبعا بفتخر بوجودي في الجامعه الام
بالمرحله الاولى كانت البكالوريوس
وكنت فخوره اني كملت برضو ماجستير من
الجامعه الاردنيه ايضا بتخصص اداره
الاعمال والتسويق
فرحله المجمعات مين جربها
صفيت الطوابير ودخلتوا على الباص عشرين
ثلاثين ورجعتوا عشره بره ما وسعوا هذا
اللي كان يصير معنا كانت تشتي في الباص
بنزل في جوا الباص نمسك الشمسيه فهاي
الرحله يعني ما بدي احكي لكم عنها
وتخرجت هديك انا سنه 98 شويه زمان يمكن
معظمكم ما كنتوش مولودين
بعدين اشتغلت في شركه الزي للالبسه برصيفه
بين عمان والزرقاء وكان راتبي ما شاء الله
ما شاء الله كان بلشت ب 100 دينار هاد
لاني متميزه بالخمسه على دفعه بالجامعه
تميزت زادوني خمس دنانير بعد سنه
بعديها
ارتبطت بزوجي اللي هو اكبر داعم لالي
وبفترض انه موجود معنا بالقاعه
اسمه رامي بطاطسه هو السند الاساسي لالي
بس تجوزنا قال لي شو رايك نكملي ماجستير
حتى كنا خاطبين قلت له مشكله انا كثير بحب
الدراسه
وقدمت وكانت فرحتي كثير كبيره بهذيك
الايام كانت تطلع القبلات بجريده ورقيه
انتم عايشين عصر نعمه انتم مش متخيلين
وكنا في السياره واشتريتها على الاشاره
وقرات كان قبولي بتخصص دائره الاعمال
والتسويق والحمد لله تخرجت بدرجه امتياز
خلال سنتين وكنت كثير سعيده انه اهلي واهل
زوجي يحضروا مناقشه الماجستير معي
الزمن يتكرر واتعرفت كثير اليوم على الناس
دارسين تسويق من الجامعه الاردنيه وكثير
سعيده وعم بشوف فريق عملي كمان فخوره يكون
موجودين معي اليوم
حاليا انا بشتغل في قرى الاطفال
كمديره للتبرعات والاتصال وطبعا هي مؤسسه
خيريه ومنظمه وطنيه تنمويه تعنى بفاقد سند
الاسري هاي سنه الخامسه
بوجود فريق عمل رائع قدرت انجز الكثير
وبوجود اداره داعمه لالي هذا اشي جدا مهم
اللي بدي احكي لكم اياه احنا مشينا بكثير
مراحل بحياتنا وفيها كان كتير تحديات
وياما ابواب تسكرت بوجوهنا وياها قابلنا
لوظايف وحاولنا انه نحصل عليها وما قدرنا
وبحكم اني انا دارسه بمدرسه حكوميه
وبجامعه حكوميه لا بمدرسه خاصه ولا بدول
الاجنبيه فالانجليزي ما كان اولويه
بالمدارس ولا بالجامعات وهذا كانك تحدي
كثير كبير لالي وكيف بدي اطور من لغتي
وكيف بدي اطور من شخصيتي لانه هاي الامور
ما كان ينشغل عليها زي ما عم نشوف في بعض
المدارس على الاقل الخاصه الان
اخدت دورات انجليزي اول ما تخرجت من
البكالوريوس لانه كان لازم اطور حالي عشان
اقدر انافس اخذت رخصه القياده اخذت دورات
طبعا ما كان في اشي اسمه اي سي دي ال
كمبيوتر اخذت الاكسل لحال والورد لحال
والباور بوينت بتذكر كنت امشي للسوق
بالزرقاء حتى اخذها بواحده من المراكز
الحقيقه عمرها ما كانت سهله وبس ما كنت
اشكي كنت اعتبره تحدي انه انا بهاي الظروف
بدي اصنع قصه نجاحي بدي اصنع طريقي واشك
طريقي بنجاح بايدي وكنت كل ما انقل من شغل
لشغل اهلي يقولوا لي ما تطلب كثير راتب
عالي ما رح يعطوك بس برضو انا ما كنت اقبل
يعني ما كنت اقبل الا اني ابدل اقصى جهد
بايدي والحمد لله كنت قادر اخذ اللي اطلبه
وطموحي واكثر واشتغلت بالاول بالقطاع
الخاصيه وبعدين اتنقلت بمنظمات العمل
الانساني اليوم
اشتغلت بمركز الملك عبد الله الثاني
للتميز وبعدين في مشروع مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبانقاذ الطفل وهلا انا بقرى
الاطفال بسنه الخامسه مع فريق عمل رائع
الرحله يا مقابله يا امتحنت وما رجعوا
اتصلوا معي وكنت دائما ادور كيف اطور حالي
اخر دورات ما كان عنا انترنت ما كان عنا
موبايل يا جماعه او شويه مش زمان بس ما
كانت عنا النعم اللي هلا بايدكم لانه
بالنسبه لي الموبايل هو كنز بتقدروا
تستخدموه لكل شيء تطوروا مهاراتكم تعرفوا
كيف تكتبوا السيره الذاتيه او كيف تروح
تقابلوا شو الاسئله راح تنسال لي اعرف عن
المؤسسه رايحها زمان ما كانت هاي الخيارات
متاحه فهو نعمه للي بقدر بده يطور حاله
انتم بالرغم كل الظروف فبسبب كل الظروف
اللي انا فيها بقدر احقق النجاح
لما عم نحكي عن عملي انا مثلا الي 20 سنه
عم بشتغل طبعا انا ام وزوجي وام ثلاث
اطفال
حياتي من ضمنها العمل خيار يعني مش ما فيه
خيار انه بدي اضل او بدي اترك انا الي 20
سنه بسوق العمل وما بشوف حاجه غير بسوق
العمل واولادي تعودوا على وجودي في الشغل
بس ارجع بيسالوني وبيعرفوا شو يعني اتحاد
اوروبي وبيعرفوا اطفال فانا اثر العمل علي
بدايه كشخصي بزيد ثقتي بحالي واي حدا فيكم
انا اكيد بشجع كل الصبايا يمكن نكمل على
اللي حكيته السوسان قصتها مش سوسن
انه الشغل كتير مهم للست لثقتها بنفسها
لاستقلال هالمادي ولا تكون قدوه وراء
الموديل لاولادها بعدين بنروح على الخطوه
الثانيه اللي اسرها على الاسره انا قدرت
اوقف جنب زوجي ونحس الوضع من المادي لحتى
احط اولادي بمدارس متميزه يمكن اسهل عليهم
الرحله اللي انا مشيت فيها
وبالتالي بقدر اركز اخليهم يسافروا يمكن
اهتم بهواياتهم ومواهبهم اللي اهلنا الوضع
زمان ما كان بيسمح لهذه الخيارات اصلا
تكون متاحه
لما انا بنزل على السوق بشتري من محلات
الاساس الاجازه الكهربائيه بروح على
السوبر ماركت انا عم بشغل المؤسسات وطنيه
عم بدعم الشاب اللي فتح السوبر ماركت وعم
بشجع الشاب اللي فتح محل موبايلات وهذا
الحكي كله على وين بنتعكس الاقتصاد كامل
بشكل عام تخيلوا لو سبتات كلهم عم
بيشتغلوا قديش حيساهموا جنب الرجل على
انهم يحسوا بوضع الاقتصادي كاسره كمجتمع
وكاقتصاد في ناس مرات بقولوا انه البنت
لما بتشتغل هي اخذت فرصه من شب وانا بدي
اقول لكم اياه لا مش صحيح هذا الحكي
لو واحده فتحت صالون شعر الكم تتخيلوا انه
الشب اللي بشتري بجيب المعدات والسشوار
والكراسي والاساس هيو اشتغل واللي بيعمل
صيانه لهاي الاجهزه برضو اشتغل واللي بوصل
الاكل كل يوم دليفري على الصالون برضو
اشتغل ففعليا احنا اوجدنا فرص وظيفيه
اضافيه للشباب من فرصه عمل وحده للست
بالارقام اذا بدنا نطلع على الاحصائيات
والتقارير للاسف نسبه المشاركه الاقتصاديه
للسيد في الاردن 13.7% وهذا رقم منخفض جدا
عالميا
ولازم كل المؤسسات بكل قطاع تشتغل عليه
النسبه الثانيه تخيلوا انه
الخساره للاقتصاد الاردني لانه الست ما
بتشتغل فيه جنب الرجل ثلاثه ونصف مليار
دينار اردني بالسنه يعني احنا اقتصادنا
بدل ما يكون كلياته صغير وبس الشباب عم
يشتغلوا فيه الذكور كل الاقتصاد بيتحسن
لما السيف بتوقف جنب الرجل بطاله النساء
31% وعلى تقرير الفجوه بين الجنسين عالميا
احنا 131 ترتيبنا من 165 دوله متخيلين قد
ايه احنا تحت في القائمه ليه لانه احنا
لازم نقود التغيير وانتو هلا جيل الشباب
شباب وصبايا اذا تفكيركم تغير عن الفكره
التقليديه اللي كنا عم نحكيها بالقصه
الاولى
رح يصير التغير الايجابي مش بس على واحد
ولا على شخص ولا على شاب ولا عصبيه فعليا
على البلد كامله على الاقتصاد وعلى
مستوانا على مستوى معيشي كل عيله بعيلتها
فالمسؤوليه كتير كبيره رح نشتغل على اشي
اسمه مين سمع بهذا المصطلح جديد صار في
اشي اسمه
العلامه التجاريه الشخصيه انا يمكن هلا
التقيتوني اليوم
او يوم بعد يوم يمكن تلاقوني على السوشيال
ميديا اصحابكم اللي كانوا معكم بالمدرسه
او بالجامعه او بشغل ثاني اذا انتم كنتم
مشتغلين فيه يمكن ما بيشوفوكم بالسنه من
مره لمرتين لكن كل يوم بشوفوكم على
السوشيال ميديا بدنا ننتبع شو بنكتب شو
التعليقات اللي بنضيفها حتى الصور اللي
منزلها انتم بتعرفوا هذا كله بشكل صوره
الذهنيه عني بذهن الناس اللي بتعرفها
فكتير بيشوفوني الناس اه والله يا نانسي
شفناكي
بهالشغل بس انا من سنه مش شايفتهم بس عم
بيشوفوني على السوشيال ميديا
السوشيال ميديا سلاح كتير حلو اذا بنعرف
نستعمله صح وللي قربوا او يتخرجوا بدوروا
على وظائف بدكم تعرفوا انه حتى المؤسسات
قبل ما تعين شخص بتفتح السوشيال ميديا
تبعه وبتشوف شو بيكتب وشو بيحكي وشو ارائه
وشو اللغه اللي بستخدمها وشو الصور اللي
بينشرها هويتكم فعليا غير الهويه اللي
بنمسكها هي هويه رقميه بدكم تديروا بالكم
لانها بتعكس شو انتم بدون ما الناس تكون
شايفتكم استعملوه كسلاح حلو كتير وانتبهوا
انه اللي بنشوفه على السوشيال ميديا هو
عشره بالميه من الجانب المشرق من حياه
الناس سفر وترقيه ومطاعم والحياه سعيده بس
في 90% جانب ممكن يكون فيه كتير احباطات
وتحديات ومشاكل بس ما حدا بيحطها على
السوشيال ميديا
الجانب الخيال اللي فيه يحبطكم
بالعكس تستفيدوا منه انه تعملوا لكم هويه
رقميه جدا واضحه
وهنا السؤال كيف بدي اميز حالي انا عرفت
معاي شهاداتي وعرفت انه في اشي هنا الفكره
اني انا بدي اشوف شو ظروف اللي جيت منها
وبسبب هذه الظروف بدي اضل عندي اصرار
وتحدي اني اثبت حالي وما اسمع الناس
السلبيين اللي راح يقولوا لي انت ما رح
تنجح انت ما راح تقدر تصير معك اشي زي ما
انت بدك اياه لا تطلب هذه زي ما انت بتوقع
تعين بهاي الوظيفه ما بياخدوك بالعكس هذول
الناس مرات ما بيصيروا سبب تحدي اني لا
انا بدي اثبت اني انا بقدر احصل هاي
الفرصه لاني انا عارف قدراتي ومهاراتي وعم
بشتغل عليها انطلب مهاره معينه مش موجوده
عندي تصميم بفتح اليوتيوب كيف بصير اشتغل
على برنامج بريزي او كيف بشتغل على كثير
برامج ديزاين جديده الادبي ذكاء الاصطناعي
بدكم تضلكم تواكبوا شو عم بصير
لانه هذا كله بخليكم تتميزوا احنا انا
بشوف عشره تخرجوا بنفس التخصص خلينا نحكي
اداره اعمال او او تسويق كلهم تخرجوا من
نفس الجامعه وجايين من نفس الخلفيات خلينا
نحكي
باخد واحد منهم بتميز ليه لانه اشتغل على
حاله تطوع بمؤسسات حتى بدون مقابل لانه
نصيحه التطوع جدا مهم وحتى وجودكم في
الجامعه اذا انتم بعدكم في الجامعات نصيحه
انكم تستفيدوا من وجودكم بالاربعين لا
تطلعوا بمجرد شهاده وهذا اشي يعني بتمنى
اني كنت بهذيك الايام استفدت منه بمجمع
النشاطات او باي جامعه اكيد فيها كثير
مجاري تطوروا هوايات ومواهب واهتمامات
وعمل تطوع واجتماعي حتى لو مش مدفوع لانه
بخلي السي في تبعتكم يصيروا تتعبى قبل ما
تتخرجوا فبيمر علي عشر سيفيات انا بختار
الشخص اللي حسيته مشتغل على حاله كتير
اكتر
خليكم دائما ايجابيين خلوا قلبكم دايما
مفتوح لمحبه الناس صدقوني حتى الابتسامه
لحالها هي جواز سفر لقلب الناس بتوصل
المسج اسرع ونفس الفكره اذا بحكيها بطريقه
ايجابيه ممكن تنقبل ونفسها اذا حكيتها
فيها تشاؤم وفيها سلبيه الناس ماتت راح
تتقبلني فيها الحياه بالنسبه الي الحياه
حلوه الحياه نعمه مجرد وجودكم هون معناته
انتم اجيتوا على اجريكم سامعيني شايفيني
معكم موبايلات يعني معكم موبايل ونت هاي
نعم 90% من سكان الكره الارضيه ما عندهم
اياها وهاي ارقام يعني بالاحصائيات فاحنا
عنا نعم كتير كبيره
نقدر هامشكر ربنا ومتى ما كنا بنشكر ربنا
هو بيعطينا اكثر واكثر الايجابيه حلوه
حبوا الناس وكل التوفيق وولدت وفيه فمي
ملعقه
عاديه
[موسيقى]